bom pessoal compartilhar um pouco da
minha história com vocês
ah eu ingressei como estudante da vida
de estudante em 1989 numa escola
particular aqui de porto alegre e na
época meus pais estavam se separando mas
mesmo assim a gente tinha uma situação
financeira considerável
a gente estava dentro do que se chamava
de a classe média brasileira
e pra quem nasceu depois do início dos
anos 90 ou não lembra daquela época a
gente enfrentava um momento de
hiperinflação do país ea cada governo
que assumiu o poder
tentava criar novas medidas novos
pacotes econômicos para tentar conter um
pouco daquela inflação
para vocês terem uma idéia aos 13 anos
há dez anos desculpa e 1993
eu já tinha conhecido cinco programas
econômicos diferentes
ah eu lembro que nessa época quando uma
família recebia o salário daquele mês
a gente tinha que sair correndo para o
supermercado para fazer o rancho do mês
porque se deixasse para a semana
seguinte para 15 dias
há aquela família perdia completamente o
poder de compra que ela tinha e foi
nessa época que o título de classe média
da minha família começou a ser ameaçada
o meu pai tinha saído da empresa que ele
tinha trabalhado por 20 anos como
publicitário e pegou a indenização dele
investiu no sonho da vida dele naquele
momento que era a construção de um
restaurante
ele só não copulou muito bem que ele não
entendia nada do negócio de alimentação
e restaurante acabou fechando as portas
antes mesmo de abrir a minha mãe também
teve a algumas tentativas frustradas na
área de empreendedorismo
então era um período muito complicado
para se empreender né
naquele período e mais ou menos por essa
época 1991
4 foi o o ano de entrada do plano real
que ajudou a estabilizar um pouco a
economia foi o ano em que o brasil
conquistou o tetra campeonato e que
infelizmente a gente perdeu o everton
sena
foi nesse fatídico 94 que eu repetir de
ano pela primeira vez na vida
eu estava na 4ª série e lá pelo meio do
ano eu comecei a me interessar pelas
aulas
eu lembro que eu chegava na aula e da
forma que eu abrisse o caderno eu
escrevia não importava se estava de
cabeça para baixo estava na ordem certa
na página certa do jeito que eu abrir eu
escrevia e lá pelo final do ano claro
depois de muita bronca a a professora
chamou a minha mãe e disse olha o
eduardo é um menino bastante inteligente
mas ele não realiza nenhum exercício que
é proposto que a senhora acha eu devo
passar ele pra quem tá série eu devo
fazer com que ele repita de ano
imagino o desgosto que a minha mãe devia
estar sentindo naquele momento né
já não bastasse todo o problema
econômico que era manter os filhos numa
escola particular
o eduardo ainda estava repetindo de ano
e ela pediu uma professora que se eu não
tivesse méritos é professora julgas que
não tinha mérito que a professora devia
me repetir de ano
e foi assim que em 1995 eu conheci
novamente a 4ª série e conhecer o
sistema público de ensino
foi uma escola pública por sorte eu
acabei indo para uma escola de ensino
básico público bastante boa
ficava perto da minha casa e fui me
adaptando aquela nova sistemática que
era o ensino público
mas não era só o ensino público não era
só o ensino desculpa da escola pública
que era um perigo por um estudante
naquele momento eu sempre lembro de uma
história de um colega que eu tinha que
estava começando a se envolver
a organização promove o tráfico na época
e um dia ele me chamou e disse olha olha
que eu trouxe e era uma arma uma pistola
calibre 22
ele mostrou na mochila dele e eu como
qualquer criança que curioso e pedir pra
pegar aquela arma para ver como
funcionava
ele me emprestou aquela arma era inverno
e eu voltei a arma dentro do casaco
fui em direção ao banheiro da escola
chegou no banheiro eu que tirei o pente
coloquei de volta engate lei
mirei numa portinha do banheiro e atirei
e por sorte não tinha ninguém ali
por sorte também não tinha uma uma bala
naquele cano de arma
se tivesse desculpa e sai um menino
daquele daquele banheiro e eu não vi que
ele estava ali eu olhei à primeira vista
não vi que ele estava
imagina se a arma estivesse com a bala
ali dentro o que poderia ter acontecido
com o menino e com a minha vida mas fora
isso o meu ensino fundamental foi
tranquilo
tranqüilamente chato como é para a
maioria dos estudantes do ensino público
é enfrentar greves do aluno enfrenta
enfrentei professores mal remunerados e
por isso desmotivados
enfrentei falta de estrutura mas fora
estava tudo certo até que chegou o ano
de 1999 e agora estava entrando no
ensino médio
eu me sentia o adulto agora está com os
hormônios toda à flor da pele né
só que chegou o ensino médio eu ainda
não tinha aprendido estudar e não
conseguia estudar e mais uma vez ao
final daquele ano
eu acabei repetindo repetindo agora pela
segunda vez ea primeira na escola
pública
só que agora não era mais uma criança
e agora eu precisava correr atrás de
algo que me trouxesse uma
responsabilidade por isso eu resolvi
procurar um estágio e aquilo funcionou
bem pra mim funcionou muito bem e eu
consegui seguir com os meus estudos e
continuam estagiando até 2002 quando eu
comecei a trabalhar numa loja no regime
de 8 horas por dia
e aí eu acabei me tornando um zumbi
naquela época eu lembro que eu acordava
às sete e meia da manhã
eu ia para a aula estudava ou tava meio
dia ia pra casa mostrava e é pra loja
chegava às duas horas na loja ficava até
às 10 11 horas na loja saía voltava pra
casa jantava e só dava tempo de dormir
porque amanhã começaria tudo de novo e
chegou lá por setembro e outubro daquele
ano
pensei 'bom eu tô com as faltas touradas
vai ser muito difícil conseguir atingir
a nota que eu preciso eu vou desistir de
novo e abandonei meu terceiro ano do
ensino médio e sair da escola
passados uma duas semanas uma professora
foi na loja onde estava trabalhando e
diz eduardo volta vai conseguir
eu tentei argumentar com ela que eu já
estava matematicamente reprovado mas ela
disse não eu acredito em ti e tu vai dar
um jeito e vai conseguir e eu voltei eu
voltei e acabei me formando no ensino
médio naquele ano a minha irmã sempre
conta uma história que é muito engraçada
que diz que quando chamaram meu nome no
palco para receber o diploma a menina
que estava sentada atrás dela disse
eu não acredito que esses caras foram lá
e foi com essa imagem que eu deixei o
colégio com mais sorte do que juízo bom
vida que segue em 2004 conseguiu
ingressar numa universidade uma escola
superior
pra começar os meus estudos em
publicidade e propaganda
na época a ufrgs e eu não tenho
sei porque eu tinha certeza que eu não
passaria nem perto o histórico escolar
que eu tinha
quem diria hein hoje está aqui né mas aí
a minha vida como estudante ela mudou da
água pro vinho como estava no lugar que
tinha estrutura e passei a gostar de
estudar eu realmente entendi o que era
estudar e aí eu me tornei um nerd
agora é moda né mas há na época me
tornei um leve um cdf
eu lembro que eu conseguia estudar e é
super bem nas provas e acabei virando
referência inclusive para os meus
colegas a ajudando os meus colegas na
época de prova e eu sempre dava gente
chegar mais cedo antes das provas pra
conseguir ajudar eles né e na época eu
consegui ser bolsista eu fiz o projeto
de iniciação científica
eu fui monitor nas cadeiras de
computação gráfica das aulas tudo isso
ainda juntamente com o estágio que eu
fazia era de oito horas ou mais na época
em que trabalhou em agências de
publicidade sabe como funciona isso
e mesmo assim eu tinha um excelente
desempenho escolar
me formei e lá por 2011 eu resolvi que
queria continuar estudando e na época eu
já trabalhava também é bom agora vou
tentar me aventurar um pouco pelo ensino
um laine nessa época conheci o promissor
mercado do ensino a distância no brasil
é lembro que estava preso pesquisando
algumas aulas na internet no youtube e
achei o canal de um professor que tinha
colocado uma série de aulas ali
gratuitamente para qualquer um é que
quisesse chegar e assistir pela aula
dele assistir e eu me senti tão tocado
com aquilo eu achei tão legal aquilo e
claro a qualidade não era tão boa mas eu
queria ajudar aquele cara e ele era caso
aumente aqui da mesma cidade que eu te
porto alegre
então eu entrei em contato com esse
professor
a gente combinou um café ea gente
começou a desenvolver um projeto juntos
ele acabou lá pelas tantas desistindo
que não quis levar aquela idéia adiante
mas eu não queria deixar aquele projeto
morrer e foi aí que em 2011 juntamente
com a juliana agente fundou o livro
ponto net que é um portal de educação à
distância focada na preparação de jovens
para o vestibular e para o enem
na época era apenas um projeto ea gente
não tinha dinheiro algum para começar
esse projeto então estavam começando a
se popular que estão a popularizar a
questão das startups
a gente foi atrás da idéia de
investidores anjo ea gente descobriu que
quando não se tem um protótipo quando
não se tem nada que seja mensurável o
investidor acaba fugindo de ti
então a gente parou pensou que a gente
poderia fazer para colocar aquela ideia
no ar e para isso a gente reuniu mais
quatro outros sócios looks que também
embarcaram junto com a gente nessa e
deram corpo ao primeiro protótipo que a
gente já ter do nosso portal e com ele a
gente lançou um curso completo de
revisão para vestibular enem totalmente
gratuito e acessível na nossa plataforma
o objetivo desse curso na época era
testar a aceitação do público e ver se
os alunos iam gostar do que estava vendo
ali eo pessoal gostou gostou bastante
inclusive em pouco mais de seis meses a
gente tava batendo a meta de 100 mil
usuários inscritos nessa plataforma
e não para por aí na mesma época a gente
conseguiu ingressar em primeiro lugar na
encubadora de negócios da espm e também
fomos os vencedores da décima segunda
maratona de empreendedorismo da unics
algo que me dá bastante orgulho
a gente tava indo tudo muito bom tudo
muito bem
só tinha um pequeníssimo problema na
época a gente não estava conseguindo
tornar a aula livre insustentável não
está conseguindo fazer o projeto andar
com as próprias pernas
e lá pelo meio de 2013 quando a gente
estava muito próximo de fechar as portas
a gente descobriu um programa que o
governo tinha na época chamado startup
brasil
e aí a gente acabou aplicando para esse
programa e fomos aceitos para participar
da primeira turma do estado do brasil e
fomos acelerados no rio de janeiro por
seis meses uma aceleradora focada em
negócios sociais com mais outras cinco
empresas
a gente voltou de volta para porto
alegre a gente conseguiu corrigir o
nosso modelo de negócios ea partir de
então a gente passou a oferecer cursos a
preços extremamente populares para que
cada aluno de escola pública tivesse
condições de poder estudar com a gente
também
em dezembro de 2016
enquanto eu faço essa palestra para
vocês a agente já reúne no livro ponto
net mais de 700 mil alunos cadastrados
ea gente mantém um canal no youtube da
da nossa empresa também que distribui
uma série de aulas gratuitas e já tem
mais de 700 mil inscritos também além de
mais de 50 milhões de visualizações de
aula
mais ou menos na mesma época que a gente
fundou ao livre com a popularização da
internet banda larga das plataformas de
vídeo diversas outras empresas de de
moxi como se chama né
surgiram ajudando também essas pessoas a
estudar online como é o caso do cão
academy da ioda city do curso era e o
próprio ted que trouxe formato diferente
de conteúdo para vocês
em 2013 o próprio youtube lançou o seu
braço de educação que o youtube do
agente fez parte da primeira leva quando
eles lançaram eu sou aquele rapaz ali
mas o canto e eles reuniram os
principais produtores de conteúdo do
brasil dentro de uma única plataforma
totalmente gratuita e acessível a todos
né
quando me chamaram agora pra participar
há aqui pra falar pra vocês sobre a meu
histórico de vida e fala principalmente
sobre educação aqui no ted
eu cheguei a questionar se eu seria a
pessoa mais indicada para vir aqui pra
falar sobre isso
não só por não tem nenhuma formação na
área mas principalmente porque aquele
péssimo histórico de educação como o
aluno que repetiu por duas vezes e
abandonam a escola no terceiro ano
mas aí eu passei revisitar a minha vida
inteira eu percebi que a educação ela
sempre teve presente na minha vida como
algo central como um norteador na minha
vida pra qualquer coisa que fosse
e aí eu percebi também que assim como eu
milhares de jovens devem se sentir
perdidos em determinado momento e até
pensar que eles não podem ter um futuro
bom porque não conseguem estudar em que
aquilo é culpa deles quando nem sempre é
assim
e foi aí que me lembrei das milhares de
mensagens que a gente recebe todos os
dias o dólar livre do nosso canal a de
diversos alunos que nos contam como a
gente conseguiu ajudar eles a
conseguirem atingir seus objetivos
e aí aí depois de quatro anos
eu consegui entender uma lição muito
importante que a vida havia tentado me
ensinar e eu não estava conseguindo
entender nesse momento é que quanto mais
a gente dividir o conhecimento mas a
gente multiplica transformações muito
obrigado a todos vocês
[Aplausos]